Film Courage: Asghar, is it true that you
view screenwriting almost like a math equation?
You piece parts together?
What is your process for screenwriting?
Asghar Farhadi (via translator): The thing
that might interest you and that I’ll
explain to you is that when I start [writing]
I am writing without any kind of calculation,
any kind of architectural overview.
It seems when you actually see the film, that
I’ve begun with the puzzle pieces that I
keep moving around until I find the final
shape but it’s truly
the opposite.
Once I’ve written a first draft summary,
it’s only then that I begin to correct and
to change the puzzle pieces in a conscious
manner.
Meaning I write in the first stage with my
heart and the rest of it with my mind.
Film Courage: You have many people waiting
for your movies.
Do you ever feel a pressure or what are your
thoughts on an audience that can be fickle
at times?
I know you’ve said previously that awards,
although they’re nice and complimentary
toward your work, are not the only reason
that you make films.
Asghar Farhadi (via translator): As I’ve
stated before these events allow the audiences
to become more familiar with the language
of my films and (for a greater number of them)
to see my films.
What I don’t like is that they go see the
film to see me more than to see the film and
where it is strong and where it might not
be strong.
Film Courage: How do you feel about your
films being framed in a cultural view instead
of a mere thought of just stories about relationships,
about people?
So when you make a movie from a Western standpoint,
it’s seen from a cultural view with some
sort of statement when it’s more about human
beings interacting?
Asghar Farhadi (via translator): It
really depends on the viewer and what their
preference is and what angle they look at
the film from.
It’s possible that some viewers in a far
away city may see the film and no cultural
aspect is important to them.
They are just interested in seeing these characters
and where they’re going.
However, as this is a realistic film and it
is made in a society and the characteristics
of that society are reflected in and can be
found in the film.
Film Courage: I know as a teenager (in the
1980’s) you were involved in a cinema society.
What would you advise to a young, Iranian
filmmaker today who wants to make movies?
Asghar Farhadi (via translator): I’ve
always refrained from giving specific advice
to try and guide someone because the advice
could in fact lead them the wrong way.
But the one thing I can say is to tap into
their unconscious to make their films, rather
than their conscious mind to start with.
We all have this incredible wealth that is
our unconscious and over time it some how
has been veiled and sunk to some depth that
we can’t access it, but if we could access
it there are unexpected and wonderful things
there.
Film Courage: Going back to those early
days of the cinema society, what was your
goal in terms of making movies?
I think it was an Eastern European film you
saw that really changed things for you, maybe?
But what did you want to say with film and
what was your goal in making them?
Asghar Farhadi (via translator): There’s
a number of things.
The one thing is that I really derive great
pleasure from filmmaking and if I were not
able to do this, life would be difficult
for me.
The other thing that is important and perhaps
has become even more so recently, is for me
to address questions I have in my films and
then in the course of the ensuing discussions
learn and grow.
Film Courage: Excellent.
Thank you.
Asghar Farhadi: You’re welcome.